[Musik]
im indonesischen tauchparadies reiter am
platz liegt das dorf sei wenngleich mit
seinen 120 einwohnern über die hälfte
davon sind kinder
sie besuchen einen ganz besonderen
unterricht also welche fischen gehen
woran müssen wir dann der nicht auf die
korallen stehen schnorcheln den abfall
nicht richtig damit wir das
nichtvergessen haben wir unser memory
wer weiß es noch wie viele fische sind
in der kategorie grünen 90
jonas müller ist gebürtiger glarner und
arbeitete früher als betriebsökonom 2014
gar er seine karriere auf lernte
indonesisch und eröffnete hier sein
lernzentrum für umweltschutz und
ökologie gehören das heißt noch ganz
viel fisch dahin kann typisch mit großer
nase oder weniger mainz ots ein anderer
fischer und rot heißt der fisch fleisch
komplett aus und das alles natur
jonas führt mit seinem lernzentrum eine
lücke denn das niveau der staatlichen
schulen ist sehr tief hier dagegen
lernen die kinder spielerisch und
nachhaltig
seit tagen werde die lerneffekt es geht
es darum dass sie sprachen du fragt
erhält also zwischen angeborenen sprach
also scheine sich das ist wichtig für
den tourismus
und sie lernen aber fischer und auch ich
wurde die heimischen sprach am mittag
setzten die kinder das gelernte in die
tat um
speer fischler steht heute auf dem
programm weil der platz auf jonas bot
beschränkt ist müssen die jüngeren
zurückbleiben
ein bot ist für die meisten bewohner
hier unerschwinglich umso größer ist die
freude der kinder wenn sie mit jonas
aufs meer hinausfahren dürfen
[Musik]
jonas müller lebt in indonesien in
südostasien
bei west papua liegt das tauchparadies
reiter am cut
etwas abseits und vom tourismus noch
weitgehend verschont findet sich das
dorf salon 3
[Musik]
hier hat jonas müller seine umwelt
schule eröffnet
[Musik]
der schweizer nicht ein warum aufnehmen
interessiert
monika peter horne hobby und die
unglaubliche schönheit der natur habe
die grünen verstärken wurde zum mister
oder für engagieren auch entstanden
die kinder haben inzwischen gelernt dass
ihre ernährung von einem intakten
ökosystem abhängt denn fisch ist ihre
tägliche nahrung
kinder schwimmt nur in der gruppe arno
zu hören
wir gehen darüber speer fischen und
schießt mir die richtung oder freunde
und kollegen mit einzuziehen ströme
kroatisch wie dann über der strecke gab
es ausgeht aber ich habe mit dem fbi
das heißt einfach strom ich das
wahrscheinlich sein
[Musik]
wasser ist auch die welt von adel dich
nur schon von berufs wegen
er ist klärwerk meister der
abwasserreinigungsanlage küsnacht
erlenbach
auch privat ist wasser seine passion
heute will er nach verschollenen
schätzen tauchen
ich mach das material parat für die
hütte nachgang zu dem frank rommel
vorstand im april die stadt über 20
darum bemühten absolvieren und erhoffen
uns natürlich naiv und auf dem rock das
ist sport lampe mit drei mann den
schlüssel für den motor unser motorrad
muss was man an tischen unter dem
schlamm vergraben sie der haben mit dem
fördergeld also mehr vermutet dass die
musiker von dem motto stand auf dem
schiffsuntergang nicht nur der dokumente
der dokumentation für die zürichsee
zeitung wurde ein zeigt im archiv kunde
aber der 58 jährige hobby archäologe
gibt nicht auf
obwohl er schon über 300 stunden im
archiv verbracht hat zusammen mit den
kollegen vom tauchclub swiss ski oder
was
adel wird von allen nur ag genannt seien
tauchclub ist ein exklusiver zirkel
nur wer einen kurs in unterwasser
archäologie bestanden hat wird als
mitglied aufgenommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
positive sprache 220 mal simulation der
rostet sie die echte vier tagen haben
wir elektro erhöht die chance aktion
das heißt markus und ich könnte stüber
und misst der motorraum könnten teil vom
zirkus monotone irgendwo liegt mit 20
minuten aber die komplett ausgerüstete
durchaus realistisch für die hobby
forscher untersuchen das wrack mit der
einwilligung der zürcher kantonsrat
jolokia dafür wird alles genau
dokumentiert
vor der abfahrt steigt die spannung der
hobbytaucher
[Applaus]
drei wochen tour
kann das team dem see noch mehr
geheimnisse entlocken gibt das wrack
auch den zweiten matrosen schulfrei
[Musik]
mal
die unterwasserwelt von rabat ist
paradiesisch
allein während eines tauchgangs erwarten
einen bis zu 300 fischarten
welche fische gefangen und welche
verschont bleiben sollen können die
kinder nun unter beweis stellen
dieser junge hat einen soldaten fisch
erwischt
[Musik]
die technik des fischens mit einem
einfachen gummiband lernen die bogen
schon von klein auf
[Musik]
man hat genug
wir haben auf dem schiff das sie haben
mit so einem besuch erinnern würde das
sind die er natürlich nie allein
das kennt doch solange ein zauberer aber
da spielt dann schon dafür dass man es
natürlich möglich schnauze voll erlöse
jonas verwendet größeres geschützt eine
selbstgemachte hat tun
[Musik]
auch für ihn gilt die regel nur soviel
zu fischen wie er auf einmal essen kann
[Musik]
es ist ein kaninchen fisch sie sind
giftig das ist gift schnell deutlich und
rap ist aber wenn ich jetzt das würde
den fingern
dann wird man apple von der haupt stunde
das somit alles im blick
vorsichtig so wie jetzt darüber so
einfach das recht gibt ihm hat das
passiert also vorher veröffentlicht die
schlimmste verletzung und sicher
passiert ist allerdings ob der poster
aufgestanden bin ich heiß für die
giftigsten auf der welt und habe ich bin
jetzt wieder besser und bietet innerhalb
von zwei minuten komplex
das gibt es eigentlich im juni prozent
von der fall tödlich die habe ich das
hier schnell reagiert und mit mit für
und ihren tablet pc sowie westlicher
sagte dass er gebraucht
aber es gibt kein gift für das produkt
in die orte weltweit und die wir haben
die musik macht ein kontinent oder also
sehr überlebt haben wir zeit bis 1 90
und abnehmen da hat sich dann irgendwann
angefangen user und da bin ich mit dem
schweizer abnehmer in der schweiz
bleiben wollte er deswegen aber nicht so
wichtig sind in die kinder von weiter ab
[Musik]
in bern liegt noch der letzte schnee
nach einem apéro ist ornella weide die
mit ihren freundinnen unterwegs zu ihren
eltern
[Musik]
die letzten sieben monate hat villa in
miami an ihrer doktorarbeit geschrieben
auf der durchreise zu den seychellen ist
sie auf blitzbesuch in der schweiz
[Gelächter]
eigentlich gibt es faktisch die
versorgung des vaters den freiheitsdrang
der tochter zu zügeln sind kläglich
gescheitert
vergebens denn nach dem biologiestudium
hat es an ella nicht in die schulstube
sondern in die weltmeere gezogen als
forscherin schon als kind träumte sie
sich in unterwasserwelten
nacht lang in haft eigentlich
da die techniker von den letzten 20
jahren im action sich aus sagen mir
immer mehr überzeugt sie ist der ist
ganz lustig wer ist also sehr dominant
aber irgendwie verrostet und irgendwie
ja immerhin getan kunden was ist
eigentlich mit roxy kollektion nach der
technik natürlich schöne orte wie ich
sie ja neben mir sachen mc2 helge besser
und deshalb in einem kommentar
foto hey eine stunde lang das ist hier
hautnah
[Musik]
auf dem zürichsee bei stefan sind ag uhr
und sein team gespannt was der tauchgang
zum versunkenen schiffswrack ans
tageslicht bringen wird
[Musik]
magie ist auch buddy markus in macht
unterwasseraufnahmen um das fragt zu
dokumentieren der rest des teams folgt
später nach so wird möglichst wenig
schlick aufgewirbelt
[Musik]
dann in 22 meter tief taucht es auf das
wrack des schiffes über 100 jahre alt
gefertigt aus massivem tannenholz auf
seiner letzten fahrt um 1910
transportierte das schiff sand ag und
sein team fanden heraus dass es mit dem
heck voran verdanken
die wucht riss das dach des motorraumes
weg
[Musik]
was hat das schiff zum kentern gebracht
ein strom ein weg
[Musik]
kg vermisst den motoren raum und findet
einen kleinen gegenstand der gelernte
maschinenmechaniker ist überrascht
[Musik]
first solar
nach dreizehn flugstunden ist ornella
weideli beinahe am ziel eine kleine
insel im indischen ozean
[Musik]
die wahl werben
ich nehme im zdf
verlogen
[Musik]
die landebahn ist nicht einmal einen
kilometer lang und für den piloten eine
herausforderung
unfassbar
ornella erwartet ein warmer empfang der
forscher kollegen und bewohner der insel
die 32-jährige hat hier über mehrere
jahre das leben von jungen untersucht
[Musik]
mitten im indischen ozean liegen die
seychellen sie bestehen aus 115 inseln
eine davon ist das ganz in der nähe
liegt das saint joseph atoll viele junge
haie leben
endgeräte warme luft
[Musik]
und doch sind seit ihrem letzten besuch
acht monate vergangen
[Musik]
wie immer zieht es die forscherin gleich
als erstes zu mehr
[Musik]
goc war
das feriengefühl ist von kurzer dauer
schon morgen steht eine exkursion zu den
haien an
[Musik]
ok
speer fischen ist anstrengend die kinder
sind hungrig große bruder ich wollte da
drüben soll ich das gut hier festmachen
jetzt geht's los stücke wie es häufig
dass importe maria für uns für sie stets
das natürlich bin ich ja vor der figur
oder wenn ein cabrio dann haben wir
schlechte aussage dass sie wie eine
familie dauer der kultur das kind das
ist einfach um mein es hat ja eigentlich
natürlich hat es die haie aber das wäre
ich nicht so wie die schweiz will sich
die familie odermatt bis k s sei sondern
kassierte dem husumer hat oder
vielleicht fisch also das muss er die im
eigentum sie
und das kam so fällt irgendwo hilfe
keine kapitals personen wo sie dann wie
mir findet die jungen jagen die fischer
die mädchen nehmen sie aus die
geschlechterrollen sind hier
traditionell verteilt und nie würde ein
kind einem erwachsenen widersprechen
schade
sie sind klein 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
was ist das problem wenn wir kleine
fische fangen
[Musik]
die konnten sich noch nicht vermehren
genau und dann haben wir erden man keine
fische mehr
wir müssen uns in geduld haben bis wir
sie essen
es ist ein tolles wo im grünen bereich
sind das ist aber die werte und doch ein
erfolg für jonas denn früher war es ganz
anders
er beschäftige mich glauben sie hat aber
mittlerweile zahlt aus chile sehr
wichtig ist für 12 alles sitzt aus und
es sieht so aus dass touristen
magnetisch und die holz eigentlich nur
noch waren wirklich große fasste gibt
dann holt es noch zu schaden
[Musik]
in der schweiz ernährte sich jonas vega
hier lebt der 28 jährige wie die
einheimischen von fisch reis und eiern
tagein tagaus hat der personalrat aber
einmal mehr seine hat oder so dass der
us hauptstadt nur einer hätte würde es
nachteile da kann man sich sehr schön zu
sehen
sprich dass er für die hinter dass jetzt
alle ruhig sitzen und capri fischer
haben oder die zu fischermeister sind
[Musik]
doch bald ist es mit der ruhe vorbei
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist etwas was die arena was für eine
story und dann machen sprachen über
weniger natur und mensch
[Musik]
wir geben sie kann natürlich ein
angedachter waren die einzigen rache zu
nehmen nein nein nein nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hätte ich zum vierzylinder motor also
schon größere also jetzt nötig sind
bedrohlich oder brasilien aber sichern
starken motor und sport oder nicht aber
ich geil das wichtigste indiz ag weiß
jetzt mit einiger sicherheit dass das
schiff erst nach 1910 gesunken ist
dadurch aus dem 14
ag ist auch kollegen schicken weitere
fundgegenstände herauf mit dem segen der
kantonsarchäologie
dass die schäferhündin hand wird es klar
funktioniert war chinesischen schwerste
aber es ist dann haben
[Musik]
dazwischen
also ich weiß wohl bei 15 fragen sind
wie große die krise ja die alte theke wo
auch zu 540 bis 19.00 ich suche die trag
versunkene schiff und titel ist man
immer wieder schäfer wo software
anbieters ist ein bestand thaksin
lohnbestandteil aufholen
die sind wirklich politik sind die
handtasche in die höhe stemmen können
schwimmer einmal ein ausgeschnittene
kleider kommt folgt zugetraut
[Musik]
das projekt ist abgeschlossen aber alle
wissen tief auf dem seegrund warten noch
viele weitere geheimnisse
[Musik]
hey forscherin ornella waidele hat den
vielleicht schönsten arbeitsweg der welt
auf der seychellen insel arros leben
gerade mal 30 menschen einst war die
französische kolonie später im besitz
der ehemals reichsten frau frankreichs
lyon beton co
heute betreibt die schweizer stiftung
save aussiehst hier ein forschungslabor
finanziert von einem saudischen mit
ornella bereitet die exkursion vor
hinter ihr ein imposanter schädel eines
pottwals den es einst an gespielt hat
kannst du mir helfen sondern
durcheinander rein daily ist der lokale
wissenschaftliche direktor der stiftung
er unterstützt anhänger auf der
expedition könntest du den anderen haken
befestigen
er liegt dort beim kabelbinder und
scheren
[Musik]
ihr ziel ist dass saint joseph atoll das
von der oz 20 minuten entfernt ist vom
autor trennt sie 1 70 meter tiefer kanal
[Musik]
spezielles know how many
frisches wasser extrem hoch wie jener
kantone und
oktober stoppen aber lebte vom himmel
das heizwasser natürlich extrem
daran ist er wie heisst
also hier und jetzt zu befahren
grenzgang toll und mit dem wort die nach
high und sie hier ganz flach ist
zerrissen wird brachten viel gibt und
ein schnellerer fahrer war der motor
zeitungen
ich musste einige kilo jetzt haben wir
hier brauchen sie große komik der
meinung sind nicht so auf die
innerstädtische bisher
[Musik]
auch einen stachelrochen zeigt sich
[Applaus]
flache momenten reihen hat einen jungen
architekten er kann es kaum erwarten und
versucht den jungen hai von hand zu
fangen ist der neue 1 zitronen hai noch
nicht gechipt münchen
[Musik]
in west-papua bricht ein neuer tag an
jonas müller macht heute frei er will
alleine tauchen gehen
dazu ist er in den letzten jahren nur
selten gekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin 2004 zum ersten mal nach oben
in der umweltorganisation die schweizer
nochmals ohne not gesagt zum tauchen und
hat einen relativ schnell die natur und
die menschen die das land verliebt und
jetzt auch hat man gebraucht und das ist
natürlich anpassen wollen heute auch
noch so dass ich ganz gut aus
[Musik]
über 1.400 verschiedene fischarten
tummeln sich hier
es ist eine andere welt magisch und
ruhig
[Musik]
dementsprechend begeistert und das beste
für die region man die derzeit bekannten
aus derzeit fungiert
[Musik]
doch das unterwasser paradies ist
gefährdet
in der nächsten folge erleben wir wie
jonas und die kinder von reiter am port
diese wasserwelten zu schützen versuchen
gleiches macht die uhr in der limmat und
auch ornella will mit ihrer forschung
den lebensraum der junghaie auf den
seychellen bewahren
[Musik]